i think before i answer any of those
questions i i should probably eat a
[Music]
reaper
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and today
we have a very very very special video
a deep dive into the twisted mind of
pepper growing legend smokin ed curry
brought to you by our friends from
bonnie plants
now if you've seen the show before
you've heard me mention smoking ed curry
i think i've called them the michael
jordan of hot chilies
and not one but two occasions i've eaten
a carolina reaper along with my friend
chilly klaus
and then of course week over week you
see guests struggling
with the last dab apollo recently ed
teamed up with body plants to make it
easier than ever for pepper heads to
grow their own hot peppers
if you're a do-it-yourself type of spice
lord you can now get four of smoke and
ed's pepper
plants delivered to your door
exclusively from bonnieplants.com
so without further ado let's delve into
the mind of one of the pepper world's
most
feared and revered characters smoking ed
curry smoking ed curry welcome to the
show
thank you sean it's an honor you grow a
lot of amazing peppers at puckerbutt
i've tried many of them
i've tried many of the sauces but i
think for hot ones fans the thing they
know you for
best is the carolina reaper when you
started growing that pepper was the idea
to set a guinness world record for the
spiciest pepper was it more like
you started building a car and then it
turned into a rocket ship
it was more like building a car and
turning it into a rocket ship
i was just looking to raise a
sub-capsuloid level on peppers when i
invented the carolina reaper but we were
already making hot sauce
and i got this pepper this year and i
was like i ate it and i was like whoa i
felt high for the first time in like
three years
you know and then boom i had my buddy
brett come over and eat it he threw up
you know so i knew i had something there
we went and got it tested that year and
that first year it turned out at
1.275 million scoville heat units
now that was the unstable pepper that
was just the start
of the process to stabilize and actually
get a genetically stable pepper
how would you explain what a capsinoid
is and talk to me like i'm five years
old
those are the compounds that our body
perceives as heat through a chemical
reaction with a nerve
called a trvp1 receptor there's no
actual heat so
it's just those are the compounds that
we
perceive as heat from peppers in regards
to peppers is it true that it's the
seeds that make them hot
uh no that's a fallacy it's the tissue
that's attached to the seed called the
placenta
that contains the capsule on the topic
are there any other
spicy misconceptions that you can debunk
one is that peppers are hot they're not
hot it's a chemical reaction
that our brain perceives as heat so a
pepper cannot
burn a hole in your esophagus or your
stomach usually it's the crap that
you're eating
that is doing that to you these peppers
they have crazy names carolina reaper
trinidad scorpion apocalypse red they
all sound like they're straight out of a
superhero movie
how do you go about naming peppers
mostly what we do is we eat peppers we
we wind up getting a pepper buzz and
then we start
throwing stuff back and forth as a tea
or one of the kids actually will name it
like
the apocalypse i know came from a child
because they thought it was the end of
the world when they tried it
what do i have to do to get a sean evans
pepper you just tell me the word
and the next one is yours my guy
the next one is yours i've heard you
mentioned that it can take up to
10 years to lock in a crossbreed so are
you
thinking about your spice game chess
moves like decades ahead
we do anywhere between 100 and 120
crosses
every year uh just so
one or two of those will make it through
the 10-year cycle
some years a few more do some years none
of them do
but i'm already planning what's going to
happen in the 2030s and the 2040s
and what i'm going to pass on to my kids
so i'm very curious about the peppers
arms race you know
how important is security how much are
you guys
at each other's throats can you can you
break that down for me because that's
probably what i'm most fascinated by
when i speak to you
one thing that happened one of the other
breeders claimed to have went into a
field and stole pepper x
they actually took pictures of the field
but it was not a
it was only a field we grew chile de
arbo and jalapenos in
but that was serious enough that the
local police the state police
the postal service and the fbi all got
involved because it involved
interstate and international fraud
how did the partnership with bonnie
plants come to be ed bonnie has been
a part of my family since i can remember
my mom grew up in the south
and bonnie plants were always in our
garden so it was kind of uh
it was kind of a childhood uh you know
heartwarming memory
to have those people come to me and say
supply us with peppers you know
i'd like to know more more detail about
how to grow a carolina reaper but before
we get into that i know ed that you are
ever the showman
uh what do you have going on there well
we might have a little bonnie plant here
with a little bit of reefer on it
and i think before i answer any of those
questions i
i should probably eat a reaper
no time like now there it goes
[Music]
now that your temperature is rising a
little bit ed can you
talk us through step by step in as much
detail as possible
how to grow a carolina reaper starting
with uh the seedling
make sure that you water the plant okay
they need
dirt they need water and they need
light okay they can live with just that
wow
second one's a charm so fill it up with
miracle grow organic potting soil
you can bury the plant until maybe
four inches is showing
me
and when you see flowers start coming
out you don't have to worry about
pollination
they pollinate themselves it's beautiful
nature tells you what the plant's
supposed to look like
so just let it grow my mouth is on fire
i'm drooling and my nose is running my
eyes are watering
but i'm getting a good buzz and i'm
enjoying life
[Music]
you know uh before we get you out of
here i do want to hit you with uh some
rapid fire questions you know i
now that i have you in the proper state
how many carolina reapers do you think
that you've eaten over the course of
your life
15 years at least three a day
25 000 what is the most overrated pepper
and which one is the most
underrated most overrated pepper in my
opinion is the moruga scorpion
it tastes like poop underrated one is
the chocolate scotch bonnet
it's the best cooking pepper there is is
there a good
on-ramp for people who are maybe novices
but curious about spicy food is there a
good way to on-ramp them
yeah get the classic hot sauce from hot
ones
just make some rice and beans put a
little bit in there and use it as a side
dish
your body will get used to the heat and
you will get used to the flavor
and you'll crave more ed why should
people buy
with bonnie plants and with smoking ed
curry rather than just going out
getting their own seeds and doing it
themselves all right that's a two-fold
question sean
one is germination a lot of people have
trouble germinating pepper seeds
bonnie takes that out of the equation
they do all the germination for you
the second one is that peppers take
approximately 150 days to produce fruit
so bonnie is also taking the first 75
days out of that process for you
and providing a plant that's only 75
days away from producing fruit
so you can enjoy that fruit for a longer
period of time
and if you want to get your hands on all
four of ed curry's pepper plants
smokin heads carolina reaper apocalypse
red orange butch tea and yellow scotch
bonnet
bonnieplants.com to pick up yours smokin
ed curry always such a blast happy i got
a chance to catch up to you
let the people know what you have going
on in your life we're getting ready for
a whole new season with body plants and
a whole new season with the hot ones
i just want to tell you guys i love you
god bless you
and i look forward to getting your world
more spicy
that's my guy that's my guy
one time you were filming at the hot
sauce expo
and i said here try this and you you
looked at the camera and said if ed
curry pulls something out of his pocket
and says try this
don't do it